an architect is building a vertical
monument the base of the monument is a
rectangular prism
there's a pyramid at the top so this
looks a little bit like the washington
monument the measurements are shown
below what is the volume of the monument
so we have this rectangular prism and
then we have this pyramid on top and so
the volume of a rectangular prism is
pretty straightforward it's just the
width times or you could view it as the
length times the width times the height
so just the prism and let me color this
prism in blue so this is just the base
right over here let's figure out the
volume of just the base so i'll call it
the volume of the
well let's call it b
volume of the base is going to be equal
to the length times the width times the
height so that is 16
times 20
times 85
and well i could write the units down
just so we see it's going to be cubic
feet 16 feet times 20 feet
times 85 feet
85 feet is equal to
something
feet cubed or cubic feet and i could
work this out 16 times 20 is going to be
320 and then i want to multiply that
times 85
multiply that times 85. 5 times 0 is 0.
5 times 2 is 10
5 times 3 is 15 plus 1 is 16. now i have
to worry about the eight right over here
keep a zero here because it's really
eighty so eight times zero is zero eight
times two is sixteen
eight times three is 24 plus 1 is 25
25 and then we add them all up zero plus
zero is zero zero plus zero zero six
plus six is twelve
and then two plus five is seven and then
you get bring down the two so twenty 27
200
27
200
cubic feet that's just the base
that's just the base over here now we
have to figure out the volume of this
pyramid and i'm not going to prove it
here and actually i'll maybe prove it in
another video and you need a little bit
more sophisticated math to be able to
prove it but it's actually pretty neat
what the formula for the volume of a
pyramid is because it's kind of what you
would guess based on if you know the va
the the area of a circle the volume
the volume of a pyramid is the length
times the width times the height of the
pyramid divided by three and the reason
why i say that's pretty cool is because
if you're looking for the area of a
triangle the area of a triangle it is
the
base times the height and you could view
the width or the length as the base of
the one of the dimensions of the base
it's the base times the height divided
by two this is you could view area as
kind of a volume in two dimensions and
volume is volume in three dimensions two
dimensions three dimensions so it seems
like that works out i i don't i can't
even visualize a pyramid in four
dimensions but i'm curious what would be
that hyper volume
what would be the formula for the
for a pyramid in four dimensions that's
something that you can think about after
this problem but with this out of the
way now that we know the formula and we
haven't proven it to ourselves but it
has a certain elegance to it so we'll
just run with it for now
so the volume of the pyramid at this
pyramid in particular we know what the
length and the width are it's the same
as the length and the width of the
actual base it's going to be 16
16 feet
times 20 feet
and then we're going to multiply it
times the height of the pyramid now you
have to be careful here the height of
the pyramid is not the length of one of
these edges right over here the height
of the pyramid is if you were to go into
the middle let's see imagine this
pyramid is transparent and if you're the
if you're at the middle of the top of
the base right here and you went
straight to the middle of the top of the
pyramid that is that is the height and
they gave us that height at 22 feet so
this is from the top of the base if we
were to go straight up not along this
edge if we were to go straight up to the
same height to the same height as the
top of the pyramid that is 22 feet so
the height over here is
is 22 feet so that gives us is going to
be 320 times 22 so let me write that
down this is going to be equal to 320
times 22
times 22.
just multiply it out so first i'll use
that too maybe i'll do it in blue
so 2 times 0 is 0. 2 times 2 is 4 2
times 3 is 6.
now i'll worry about this 2. well this
is really 20 so we have to put a 0 here
2 times 0 is 0 2 times 2 is 4
2 times 3 is 6. and we add them all up 0
4
you get a 10 bring out the 1 and 7 000.
so the numerator right over here the
numerator the length times the width
times the height is seven thousand and
forty but we actually have to divide it
by three if we just lifted this this
would be the volume of a cube of those
dimensions but we care about a pyramid
so we actually have to divide it by
three so it's going to be that quantity
divided by 3 and it's feet times feet
times feet so it's cubic feet
so it's going to be that divided by 3
cubic feet that's going to be the volume
of the pyramid
volume of the pyramid and let's actually
figure out what this is so if i take
three and two
and i could use a calculator but that
wouldn't be as much fun three into seven
thousand and forty three goes into seven
thousand two times two times three is
six
subtract seven minus six is one bring
down the zero three goes into ten
three times three times three is nine
subtract you get one bring down the four
three goes into 14 four times
four times three is twelve subtract
subtract bring down the zero
three goes into twenty
six times six times three is eighteen
you subtract you have a remainder two we
could keep going and have a decimal or
we can just write that the volume of the
prism is
2346 and two with the remainder so two
and two two-thirds
and two-thirds feet
and two-thirds if we kept dividing we
would get .66666 and we would just keep
on repeating forever so that's the
volume of the prism we already know the
volume of the base the volume of the
base is let me align things the volume
of the base
is 27
27
200
feet cubed these are both in cubic feet
and then we can add them together so
you're definitely going to have the
two-thirds there you're gonna have to
the two-thirds six plus zero is six
four plus zero is four
three plus two is five put the comma in
both of them two plus seven is nine and
then you just have this two over here so
the volume of this entire washington
monument like looking thing is 29
546 and two-thirds
cubic feet and we're done